I'm gonna need you to work a double
tomorrow it's too weak so let's message
so much to do cause I have to pull some
doubles this week
we only going to make the five times be
the opponent you're going to track down
mr. McDade and you're still sitting here
because I'm so sorry turns out that I
actually do have to go to office tonight
of course Hideo she said she's gonna
stay home and it lasted like 10 minutes
she's my daughter and she barely speaks
to me I'm just supposed to believe in
the magic of Christmas if she can't dive
into a tree full of Christmas presents
so what's her to put to answer when I
call I wanted to see her mama is
successful I wish things were tired
[Music]
[Music]
portray me oh that's not it
do we just tell our families the truth
Merry Christmas I'm trapped in someone's
body who's ready for breakfast okay
there's a lot to go over
I've run a record label run I'm trying
to pick up as many shifts as possible
and there's a lot of activities at
school that are committed to one of
those cookies those aren't your cookies
well I bought them so they're mine and
I'm giving them to you so they're yours
Easy's I thought that we could decorate
the house for Christmas I can't just
drop everything and have a Christmas
revival you need to say no more it seems
like you really figured out my life for
me what happened in here mom is bringing
Chris's back let's get our families
together tomorrow maybe having everyone
together will spark something switch is
back you know it's really good to have
people over for Christmas again with
popcorn
[Music]
you